JEN: Today, we're talking about
VM migration, custom voice,
and disaster recovery.
I'm Jen, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Google Cloud VMware Engine
helps simplify your migration
to Google Cloud.
The service provides a
dedicated, software-defined
data center that allows you to
continue to use the core VMware
applications you need to run
your business in the cloud
without changes to your
tools, processes, or policies.
In a recent survey by IDC, they
found that 78% of businesses
realized payback in one year
or less after they migrate.
Learn how to maximize
your returns on the blog.
We are excited to announce the
general availability of custom
voice in our Cloud
text-to-speech API,
a new feature that lets
you train custom voice
models with your
own audio recordings
to create customized
experiences.
For businesses looking to
build a strong brand identity,
this is a game changer
for customer experiences.
Check out the blog for supported
languages and more detail.
There are many reasons why
locality restrictions need
to be taken into consideration,
and it's something chief
information security
officers and resiliency
officers need to factor in.
A balance needs to be met
between taking advantage
of your best
features of the cloud
while meeting your
locality requirements.
Google Cloud helps you meet
your business's objectives,
whether your architecture
is all in on Google
Cloud, a hybrid pattern which
may be on-premises and Google
Cloud, or on Google Cloud and
an alternative cloud provider.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.